y los abrazos vuelven a los aeropuertos
internacionales y australia
a las 18 meses de restricciones por el
19 con emociones encontradas este
primero de noviembre y los australianos
completamente vacunados pudieron volver
a casa
un poco aterrador y emocionante he
vuelto a casa para ver a mi madre que no
está bien para embarcarse en un vuelo
deben mostrar además una prueba de kobe
19 negativa
regresamos y sólo la atmósfera en el
avión era como antes del cob y todos
subimos a horneo todos hicimos lo que
solíamos hacer y fue simplemente
excepcional
aquellos australianos que aún no hayan
recibido la vacuna seguirán enfrentando
restricciones de cuarentena según el
ministerio de exteriores unos 47 mil
ciudadanos o residentes permanentes
quieren regresar al país pero la mayoría
de turistas internacionales deberán
esperar para entrar a australia por
ahora sólo se permitirá la llegada de
visitantes vacunados provenientes del
vecino nueva zelanda la determinación de
reabrir las fronteras corresponde a un
cambio en el enfoque a la hora de
enfrentar la pandemia el país insular
habría buscado mantener en cero los
casos de contagio ahora opta por
convivir con el virus apoyado en una
fuerte tasa de vacunación los estados
más poblados de nueva gales del sur y
victoria completaron la tasa de
inmunización del 80 por ciento de la
población mayor de 16 años las ciudades
de sídney y melbourne fueron las
ciudades del mundo con más días de
cuarentena los confinamientos más
recientes consecuencia de la llegada de
la variante delta
las cifras de australia son bajas y se
comparan con los países más afectados
por el joven 19 contabilizando unos
170.000 500 contagios y menos de 1.800
fallecidos